casey frey's get the f out my way type
way is one of the most artfully produced
videos online today
the video tells the story of a man
rejecting criticism and using dance to
express his true self but within such a
seemingly simple story frey uses
innovative film language and symbolism
to create not only an addictive to watch
viral video but also a cinematic
masterpiece that continues to impact the
dance videos we see today
first we see the main character chop a
piece of wood then the camera pans up to
a medium shot notice how the character
straightens up to full height as the
camera follows him this movement with
the camera adds energy to the shot
and guides our eyesight to his first
shoulder dance move near the top of the
frame
this same camera movement later
visualizes his connection with his good
alter ego
after the good alter ego pulses his
chest we cut to the main character and
both he
and the camera are looking inward but
then they both move outward
showing how the good alter ego's
contagious energy infected him on the
inside from here the camera moves with
full force it travels up his body as his
energy moves from his foot
up to his hips then to his arms and his
good alter ego similarly moves with the
camera as they connect
frey uses matching shots to seamlessly
transition between the two characters as
they move as one and they finally join
forces in the final frame of the video
to add contrast to this connection the
bad alter ego is filmed in a mostly
static frame and the camera doesn't
follow his movements at all
in his last shot he rejects the movement
entirely frank gives his video energy
not just from the camera but from his
cuts like when he cuts to the beat of
the music
he also skips frames to make his
movement appear more snappy or when he
flips off his bad alter ego repeats
frames to add emphasis to his leg and
hand movements
these cuts combined with the camera
movement create a sequence with an
electric hypnotizing energy to really
get a feel for how well he executed this
video
compare it to the countless recreation
videos while many of them are great they
still reveal just how much precision
frey put into the editing and camera
work in the original but get the f
out of my way type way is more than just
a snappy dance video it has its own
story one with a complete hero's journey
the main character has a call to
adventure when starting his dance but he
refuses the call
after getting rejected then he meets a
mentor who helps him cross the threshold
overcome the abyss of rejection and
transform the story's meaning can be
interpreted in many ways
and i'm not the first to acknowledge it
feels like it's about the workers
revolution
it can be read as the story of a working
class man rejecting his manual labor job
and joining a collective in that case
the heartbeat is a symbol of the
awakening of class consciousness in the
worker and the bad alter ego is a symbol
for the ruling class who wants to
maintain the status quo
there's even a prominent sign on the
glass door that slides across the frame
that says this property is under video
surveillance
a message which makes the area feel like
an intrusive work zone but i think a big
reason frey's video has remained so
relevant for so long
is because of its universal message of
rejecting the haters and embracing your
true self
that general appeal may partly explain
why the video became its own meme format
in this meme the bad alter ego can be
any negative force
and the main character is a rejection of
that instruction and phrase video
continues to impact the dance videos we
see
online it's one of the most popular
examples of having the camera follow the
movement of the dancer a technique that
has become a dance video staple
and the storytelling in his dance moves
sets a standard for character-driven
choreography and for anybody who doesn't
appreciate the cinematic artistry of
this video
all i have to say to you is get out my
way
[Music]